it is time for hate mail and we've got
something very cool we are trying to
stay topical with hatred mail intros so
our professional hatred male interpreter
has voiced some new hatred mail intros
the first of which I'm premiering today
I think these are very timely let's take
a listen to hey treat male teachers can
buy their own school supplies but we'll
throw in the Glock for free Patriot Man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom that's exactly right we just
don't have the money for everybody to
even have their own book in school
they're gonna have to share some 7th
edition ratty dog-eared book but how
about firearms for all teachers because
we've always got money for that I like
it when hatred mail is topical it's a
good slogan it's like you know a chicken
in every pot a Glock in every teacher's
holster I like it
I mean I hate it obviously but I like
pointing out the absurdity of it ok
let's get into this week's a treat male
so logic dictates that the Liberals are
guilty right Pakman Oh
so you inspected the voter rolls oh wait
you didn't
so pac-man is a slimy little worm yet
again this is the biggest SJW circle
jerk i have ever seen I hate you park
man i how you get gang-raped
you disgust me yeah this is what we
would call a Hillary really lost the
popular vote conspiracy theorist because
since I didn't inspect the voter rolls
clearly Trump is right that three to
five million quote illegals voted for
Hillary Clinton right I think that
that's sort of the conspiracy theory
that this one connects to oh you have to
verify all 150 million votes absolutely
the 2016 election otherwise you just
don't really know what happened turn
hatred mail into something positive
give a middle finger to the hatreds as I
like to say pats flipping me off right
now but he that that's unrelated that
has nothing to do with hatred mail he's
just really angry use the coup
encode hey tree at 40 when you sign up
for membership at david pakman.com slash
membership it'll save you 40% off of
membership and it'll also send a nice
little fu to the hatred